tweet me some stupid sentences I'm gonna
do something with your sentences this
recording yeah full of her Feeny's never
mind
just look mine was because my hair was
doing some crazy shows in there whoa is
this on used to wear here never it is a
video that's happening right now Chester
and I would play the whisper challenge I
thought this was the stupidest challenge
ever but every video that I watch of
someone doing this I laughed so hard at
I just watched jenna Marbles and
Julianne do it and it's so funny it's so
stupid but it's so funny so I thought we
would play are you ok we don't know the
whisper challenge is basically like
whether or not you can read someone
else's lips you say something well know
the person has headphones on the to try
and guess what you said I tweeted out
asking you guys to send me ridiculous
sentences so I could say them to Chester
and he could try and figure out what I'm
saying why is that dog meowing what what
are you talking about why is that done
with meowing what is this song about why
is that dog meowing [ __ ] fireflies play
the piano I don't know use this a.m. why
I'm not your patient I decide what is on
why is the dog going rock rock stars
Mountain Dew pancakes are the Socrates
of breakfast foods pancakes and sausages
are breakfast foods close pancakes are
the Socrates of breakfast foods back
exercises is our breakfast what is
flying around your face
what's fireflies I don't know how does
this gamer though can I ask you it lamb
so uh yeah okay I might let a skew to do
again all right have to give me yet best
guess your best guess oh okay what is
flying around your
face fire crotches are fun I can see
Russia from my house I wasn't paying
attention this is real a lot harder than
I thought it was gonna be I can see
Russia from my house I kiss a fresh man
in front of my house nice mayonnaise
lice be nice nice mayonnaise nice
panties
penguins are the only thing that I don't
have playing with all is the only thing
I don't have
penguins are the only thing I tank Reyes
hey Chris the only thing I don't know
how to penguins and the only pancakes
Hank Reid what are you saying at the top
in essence penguin I did only thick bed
rest
Thanks favorite penguin pain Chris
penguins pancreas penguins what do you
say penguin hey why using penguins
you're saying it funny I'm not you
saying it funny
getting penguins penguins penguins pet
penguin what is okay now hahaha
okay payment is it hangman's penguins
pancreas penguins famous tourist I think
my whole life I've been saying penguins
is it team wins yeah you ready but are
you perfect imagine being a strawberry
fish balls are game imagine being
strawberry michael buckley where are you
imagine being strawberry peach pills
imagine being a strawberry basketball
drops imagine backstreet boys traffic
what is it imagine being a strawberry ah
don't wanna ever okay okay the Koala
jumped over the turtle to get the one
time over the goats the Koala jumped
over the turtle to get an apricot that's
a long one
the goat jumped over the goose and I
lost it the cool ha and the line jumped
over the goes the Koala jumped over the
turtle come on jumped over the goose the
Koala the Koala jump doe some children
the girl jumped over the true Lily oh
what the turtle surely come to herd the
turtle jumped over the Chewie jumped
over the turf yeah boo boo
there was if you're just you're arguing
in you know what ha ha ha the turtle
Shaku Jerry federal guchi turtle Julie
turtle show love turtle shell is it the
Koala jumped over the turtle to get an
apricot Oh stupid these are stupid
sentences each of them hock a loogie on
a Dookie look under the truly hawk a
loogie on a loogie a loogie hawk a
loogie hawk a loogie on a Dookie hawk a
loogie on you on a Dookie on you Lee
Dukey
Judy hawk a loogie a loogie on Judy you
key for Judy oh are you doing a collab
with grace Helbig are you gonna tap into
Selma oh are you doing a collab with oh
are you in time would grace Helbig
what Donham oh oh are you doing a collab
with great are you gonna get time with
turtles
grace Helbig grace Helbig oh are you
doing a collab oh are you doing a collab
with grace Helbig you got it yeah did I
recognize
Hey are we done yeah yeah one more set
one more time go see
Chester see in RocketBallz [ __ ] don't
see Chester see in rockabilly Jessica
how do we end it
I don't know this isn't really a game
because there's no real winner that is I
feel like I won okay I'll let you have
it because I don't mean no I mean not
one there's nothing better just like I
just felt like I won we did the whisper
challenge congratulations to us make
sure that you go see Chester see and
Rock of Ages yeah yeah New York City
also go over and check his channel and
subscribe because there's a video over
there is there I just said it so now you
have to put a video over there wouldn't
have to be read by I don't know haha
dookey dookey dookey dookey dookey
dookey poor Judy